meanwhile in the hall of justice justice
league action so I was very iffy on this
whole show as a general premise and and
I haven't seen every episode that is
there but I did see the four episodes
they crammed together sort of the hour
premiere of this thing I I think that is
enough to be able to give my feelings on
the show as a whole and thumbs up it's
not perfect i'll sort of get into some
of my nitpicky stuff later on but the
short version is this is fun and it's
punchy and it's fast-paced and how
fast-paced it is really kind of glosses
over a lot of the things that i kind of
wish would be different or would be
better but i'll sort of come back to
that so the mission statement of this is
to basically be just the action scenes
out of the sort of thing that the old
Justice League and Justice League
Unlimited TV shows used to do bringing
back some of the voice cast from those
shows it's a different animation style
and slightly more stylized art that is
not my preference and some of the
redesigns I don't care for there's also
inconsistencies in the way eyes are
designed like some characters are they
only have pupils some have full is I
really didn't care for the look of the
Martian Manhunter but it it's a mixed
bag and none of them feel like they
missed the mark they're just not all
quite to my liking now when I first
heard that they were doing this
15-minute action based version I was
just afraid that they were going to cut
sort of all the flavor out of it and
then word came that was gonna have more
of a humor bend that I went oh god are
they gonna do sort of Teen Titans go but
for the Justice League now to be fair I
actually rather like Teen Titans go but
it is obviously a very different piece
from what the old teen titans was and
this is not that drastic a departure it
is lighter it is more fun it is action
heavy but it's basically just so that
you'll sit there for six minutes and go
yeah that's awesome that is sort of the
goal of the show and for the most part
it pulls it off like I said we've got
some returning voice guys I mean the big
one the big one
Kevin Conroy is back as Batman and he's
as good as he always is he can do Batman
super serious like he did in the Arkham
games he can do Batman in a lighter tone
thing like in this and the the jokes are
there they just they just sort of come
and they don't they don't do a whole lot
of but stopping like in doing a rimshot
to highlight the junk they make the joke
in the key movie because that's how
fast-paced this is and that's sort of
what I meant when I say the the pace
glosses over some of the issues because
some of the issues that i had like I
they have Mark Hamill voicing Swamp
Thing now I love Mark Hamill I love his
voice work he's not a good match for
swamp thing and like I said there were
some character design things I didn't
love but the thing is the thing is so
fast-paced and it's not just fast pace
it's not like again to make the
comparison into Teen Titans go it's not
just bouncing all over the place I mean
it's so tight and there's so little fat
on the thing that even when something's
bothering you it's gonna be moved passed
so quickly that it doesn't leave much of
a of an irritant behinds like I didn't
care for that out but here's something
that I do like so yeah I'm already
forgetting that and the jokes are like
that too they make they make jokes sort
of either mid action or like they pause
like for a half second to make a joke
and then back into the action and the
jokes for the muffler really made me
laugh some of them are more low-key and
based in the characters some are more
broad I mean if if you know the Justice
League if you know this cast of
characters you are going to get the
biggest laughs out of that because while
none of the jokes are or the stories or
anything depends on you having pre
knowledge of these characters the show
doesn't have time to stop and explain
who these people are for you so if you
already know who Booster Gold is who
Plastic Man is and what their
personalities are like you watch your
gonna be holding your side you're gonna
be laughing so hard at some of this
stuff I mean this is never going to have
the lasting impact that that Justice
League show had I mean the reason that
show was so good is because it told
great stories with depth and depth of
character and this kind of has the depth
stripped out of it so while this is
wonderful while at last it doesn't leave
a particularly lasting impact on you
after you've seen it but you know what
during the time that it's on it is able
last so if you enjoy animated superhero
stuff at all if you like the Justice
League anything like that check out
justice league action even if you got no
past this by it look just watch that
block of four episodes the for all
together is called shazam slam it's only
an hour and I think that's enough to
judge whether or not it's worth it for
you to keep coming back for me yeah
definitely worth it and I can't wait to
see some more of this stuff so just
sleek action have you seen any of it if
you have drop something down in the
comments and let's talk about it don't
forget to Like subscribe why don't you
hit that little bell down there so you
get notifications when I put new stuff
up check me out on Twitter or a Council
of geese give a listen to the counsel of
geeks podcast on iTunes and stitcher and
as for me I'll be back as soon as I can
get my next fix